By putting together all of these pieces,
you should be able to create
a presentation about your prototype for
any audience.
It's important to remember
though that you'll be
making a lot of these presentations if
you want to become an entrepreneur.
Persistence will be key moving forward,
both in improving your prototype and
in improving your presentation.
The important thing to remember is that
nobody gets everything they need to run
a business off of their first demo.
And that every time you make a prototype
that gets poor feedback from users or
a presentation that
doesn't wow your audience,
you're learning more about the task,
and more about how to move forward.